in this video you're going to learn how
to work with linear programming or
optimization problems as they're
sometimes called we're going to go
through two word problems together one
where you have to maximize something and
one where you have to minimize something
so let's dive in and I'll explain as we
go how to work with these types of
problems so the first example it says a
company makes two products widget X and
widget y widget X yields a profit of
four dollars and widget yields a profit
of three dollars overall only 48
products can be made per day the company
wants to make at least twice as many of
product y as of product X how many of
each product should be made to maximize
the profit now my first tip for you is
that when you're trying to maximize or
minimize in these types of problems I
would write that objective what's called
The Objective function first and that
will help you to Define what your
variables are so in this case in order
to maximize profit let's say P for
profit equals
rigid axial is a profit of four dollars
so that would be four dollars times the
number of product X that are made plus
three dollars
times the number of product y that's
made so this is our objective function
or what we're trying to maximize
now we want to talk about our
constraints so what are constraints well
constraints are things that are like
inequalities so constraints
and let's take a look at that so here it
says overall only 48 products can be
made per day so that means the number of
product X and the number of product y
added together has to be less than or
equal to 48 units so that's one
constraint the other constraint is the
company wants to make at least
twice as many of product y as of product
X so that means that the amount of Y
that's made has to be greater than or
equal to 2 times the amount of product X
that it's made
okay so now the other thing you have to
pay attention to is with these two
products could you make a negative
number of these products well not really
the least you could make would be zero
so this is kind of implied that X has to
be greater than or equal to zero and Y
also has to be greater than or equal to
zero now X greater than or equal to zero
x equals lines are vertical lines so
greater than or equal to zero would be
to the right of the y axis Y is greater
than or equal to zero y equals lines are
horizontal lines that's saying greater
than or equal to zero is above the x
axis so that's going to put us here in
the first quadrant so that takes care of
these two inequalities now let's graph
these other two inequalities so this
first one here you can rearrange this
into the Y equals MX plus b form the
slope intercept form or you can do what
we call the intercept method where you
set X to Zero and that would put y up
here at 48
and then if we set y to zero you can see
x equals 48 so let's put that about here
so 48 comma zero and if we draw a line
now it's equal to so that means it's a
solid line if it was less than or
greater than but not equal to be a
dashed or dotted line and I could keep
going but in this case we know we're in
the first quadrant and then if we do a
test Point let's say for example I do
this origin Point here 0 0
0 plus 0 is 0 is that less than or equal
to 48 yes so that means that this side
of the line is the true side this side
is the false side if this was false we'd
shade the other side so you're just
testing to see which side is true so
that's going to put us right here okay
so I'll just shade that lightly here
and then for the other inequality Y is
greater than or equal to 2x this is kind
of like y equals MX plus b where B is 0
and we're basically going up two over
one up two over one so this is a line
that looks something like this with a
slope of two okay and here when the Y is
by itself on one side of the inequality
y controls a vertical Direction up and
down so if the Y values are greater than
or equal to that means we're going to be
shading above this line so that's going
to be on on this side of the line see
above and so that's going to put us
right there now notice that where these
regions overlapping they're overlapping
right here
I'll kind of shade this in a little bit
darker for us
in that triangular region and this is
what's referred to as the feasible
region it's the region that satisfies
all of our constraints but what's
interesting once you find this feasible
region your maximum or your minimum is
going to be at one of these vertices of
this like polygon or the shape that's
formed so what you can do is you can
take a look at these points now we have
this point here zero zero we have this
point here zero comma 48 but we have to
solve for this point right here where
these two lines intersect so we're going
to treat these just like equations like
X Plus y equals 48 and y equals 2x
and what we can do is we can do a
substitution so if y equals 2x let's put
2x in place of Y
so now we have 3x equals 48 divide both
sides by 3 and you can see that x equals
16. now if we put 16 back in here or
here it doesn't matter you can see Y is
going to come out to 32 and so that's
the you know the coordinates of this
point right here is 16 comma 32. so what
we're going to do is we're going to use
those vertices of that feasible region
to see you know which one is going to
give us a maximum profit so let's go
back now to our objective function okay
our thing that we're trying to maximize
or minimize in this case our profit
let's see let's take this point here so
if x is 0 4 times 0 is 0.
3 times 48 is
144 so 0 plus 144
is 144 for this point let's do 0 0 next
4 times 0 is 0. 3 times 0 0 0 plus 0 is
0. so this one's going to be 0 here
which makes sense if you sell or if you
make none of the either of the products
you're going to have a zero profit and
then let's check this point here 1632 4
times 16 is 64 and 3 times 32 is 96 and
if we add that together let's see that's
160. so what that tells us
is that this is giving us the maximum
profit of 160 dollars if we manufacture
16 of product X and 32 of product Y and
that'll satisfy our constraints but yet
maximize our profit so let's take a look
at another example where we're trying to
minimize something okay for example
number two let's dive into this one it
says a fitness company sells two brands
of nutrition bars
super bar ax costs seven dollars per bar
and it contains 20 grams of protein and
four grams of fat fantastic bar y costs
four dollars per bar and it contains 10
grams of protein and six grams of fat
say that a bodybuilder wants to consume
at least 140 grams of protein and at
least 60 grams of fat per day how many
of each bar should they consume to
minimize their cost okay so before we do
this problem this isn't nutrition advice
make sure you talk to your doctor or a
nutritionist to find out what you should
actually eat here but in this particular
problem let's go ahead and figure out
what we're trying to minimize we're
trying to minimize the cost so let's
write that objective function first so
the cost is what it's seven dollars for
super bar X so seven dollars times the
number of the super bar X Plus
it's four dollars for fantastic bar why
so this is going to be the cost equation
this is what we're trying to minimize
okay our objective function now let's
look at our constraints like kind of the
restrictions here and the restrictions
are that this bodybuilder person wants
to consume at least 140 grams of protein
per day but it looks like
um
the first bar bar ax contains 20 grams
of protein so that's 20 grams times the
number of that X brand nutrition bar
plus the Fantastic bar y it contains 10
grams of protein so that's going to be
10 times y
okay and when you add that together that
has to be greater than or equal to 114.
now the fat they also want to consume at
least 60 grams of fat per day so at
least means greater than or equal to 60
grams
and it says that uh
the first bar bar x super bar X it
contains four grams of fat so four times
the number of bars here you're going to
get let's say you consume five of these
that'd be 20 grams of fat
and for fantastic bar y that contains
contains six grams of fat so six times
the number of Bary okay good so now we
also have to take into account those
implied domains that you can't really
consume a negative number of each bar so
it has to be greater than or equal to
zero for bar X and greater than or equal
to zero for bar Y which again that puts
us into the first quadrant here
okay so we took care of those two
constraints now let's plot these now
generally when the variables are on the
left side of the inequality I like to do
The Intercept method where I set X to
Zero and solve for y so if x is 0 here
you can see y would be 14. so let's just
say this is zero comma 14. if Y is 0 0
times 10 is 0 dividable sides by 20 you
can see that X is coming out to seven so
let's just say this is 7 0 here
and this is a greater than or equal to
so equal to means it's a solid line
and I can do it the test Point method so
if I put 0 0 our origin in here that's
going to be 0 plus 0 is 0 is that
greater than or equal to 140 no so this
is the full side of our line the true
side would be this side so we can shade
uh like that
okay and then the other inequality let's
do the same thing if we set X to Zero
divide by 6 you can see Y is 10 which is
going to be somewhere over here
and if Y is 0 6 times 0 is 0 divide both
sides by four you can see X is 15 some
way somewhere way over here
and again we have greater than or equal
to so equal to it's a solid line
greater than let's double check now what
we're going to do is we want to do a
test point so we pick 0 0 that's going
to be zero plus zero is zero is that
greater than or equal to 60 no so this
is the false side we want to shade on
the other side of this line so that's
going to be right here
okay and so now what we're looking at is
where do all these inequalities overlap
well you can see we're above this line
we're above this line so our shaded
region here are what's called our
feasible region is going to be right
here
see if I can shade that in here a little
bit darker for us so basically it's like
kind of this shape here and going out
right but we're trying to minimize the
cost so what we're going to do is we're
going to test this point
uh this point right here and this point
right here that's going to satisfy our
constraints but then we can see which
one's going to minimize our cost
let's find out what this point of
intersection is here we're going to have
to solve a system of equations so we're
going to treat these just like they're
equal signs we're going to say 20x Plus
10y
is equal to 140 and this equation here
4X plus 6y is equal to 60. now what we
can do is we can multiply this bottom
equation by negative 5
and the reason I'm doing that is because
that will give us a negative 20x and
when I add it to this top equation the
X's will cancel each other out so this
would be minus 30y equals negative 300.
so let's add these equations together
the X's cancel 10y plus negative 30y is
negative 20y 140 plus negative 300 is
negative 160 and if we divide by
negative 20
Y is coming out to 8. now if we take the
8 we can put it back into either
equation I'll do this one here 6 times 8
is 48
okay so that's 4X plus 48 is equal to
60. subtract 48 from both sides 40 4X
equals 12 divide both sides by 4 and X
is coming out to 3. so this point right
here is the point 3 comma 8. so let's go
ahead and test those points now into our
objective function and we're trying to
maximize or minimize and let's start
with this point here so 7 times 0 is 0.
4 times 14 is 56 0 plus 56 is 56.
so what that means is it would cost
fifty six dollars to consume zero of
nutrition bar X and 14 of nutrition bar
y
let's go down to this point here 15 0 7
times 15 is a hundred and five four
times zero is zero 105 plus 0 is 105 so
it costs 105 dollars if you consume 15
of nutrition bar X and zero of nutrition
by our Y and then here at this point
three eight seven times three is twenty
one four times eight is
32 if we add those together we get 53 so
this one is costing 53 dollars if we
consume three of nutrition bar X and
eight of nutrition bar y we which one's
giving us the lowest cost it looks like
this point right here fifty three
dollars would be three of bar X and
eight of bar y to satisfy all the
constraints but yet minimize the cost
now you might be saying Mario isn't it
always the one in the middle well it
really depends on the problem it depends
on the objective function it depends on
your constraints it really depends but
you want to check each of the points
that are on the vertices of that shape
that polygon that's formed from the
overlapping regions so great job if
you're able to follow these two word
problems if you want more practice check
out the video I did previously right
there talking about the same topic
optimization or linear programming I'll
see you over in that video